Alright, everybody, so this is going to be the lost course update. This is basically the part two of the course update. And starting off, I'm going to teach you a trading model that is called the JYGANOT and it is basically, if not the best, one of my best, sculpting no daily
trading models. It works on all time frames. So whether it's one minute, 30 seconds or
five minute, it will work the same. Now it is very simple and you must know what an inverse
free body gap is. So simply what it's an inverse for the gap. So let's assume that we have a
a fair value gap here. Now price made a higher high, higher low, and then a higher high.
Now inside this higher high, we have a fair value gap. Now when price is here, when price
is here, right, it is still a fair value gap. But if price closes below the fair value
gap, right, in this leg, this leg, closed below this fair value gap. Now once that happens,
it becomes inverse fair value gap. So remember that. When price went up there, we had a fair value gap,
but then it was not respected and it was broken through like this and the candle closed. Notice what
I said, the candle closed. Once the candle closes, this fair value gap becomes inverse fair value gap.
All right. So now what is the model? So we have, you know, a higher high, a higher low, and then a higher high.
This higher high must have only one fair body gap. So this should not be multiple fair body gaps here.
Okay. So in this instance, for example, let's say that this right here is the only, was the only
everybody gap in this leg. All right. And let's say, all right, so we have this
early gap. We have to wait for a formation of the inverse, we get once the
inverse, for the gap is formed, we can take, look to take our entry. So what are
the rules? Number one, look for a liquidy sweep. All right, it could be any liquidy
sweep. All right, once the liquidy sweep is done, mark out the free everybody gap
and make sure that there's only one fair value gap in the leg that swept the
liquidity, right? So over here you can see we swept this high over here, right? And
this leg only had one for the gap. Now what if you're looking at this on one
minute but there are like multiple fair value gaps here? What you can do is move
higher. So if there are multiple fair value gaps go to two minute timeframe and
and see if you get one fermil gap.
If there are multiple fermil gaps on two minute time frame,
go to three minute or four minute
and keep going higher until you see one fermil gap.
It is very important that there's only one fermil gap
in the leg that breaks the structure
or sweeps the liquidy, right?
It is very important.
Now, all you're looking for is after liquidy sweep,
you're waiting for a formation of the inverse fermil gap,
right?
And then you're looking to take your entry on the retest
or on the body close.
So once the body closes, you can enter directly
or you wait for a retest.
So close in virtual gap forms,
wait for a retest and you target the most closest low.
So this is where the price action is gonna be,
look below and the closest low that you see,
that is gonna be your take profit one
or your entire take profit level
or a place where you should be going break even.
So let's assume that this low right here
was the closest low here, okay?
Now, once price takes out this low, right?
You can do three things here.
Once it happens, you go break even
and target the higher time frame draw on liquidity
or what you can do is you can take
30 to 40% of your position off here,
move your stop to break even.
and target some other form of higher time from liquidity or a significant level.
Or you can take your entire take profit level here, but make sure you are getting at least one
to one of the rest of the world and how would that happen? I would go short here. First off,
I will move my profit level to this level. Now, I will decrease the stop loss key,
decreasing the stop loss, right? Until I get one to one. But if my stop is higher than the high over here,
I can then reduce it so I can get more residual water out of this range. Right? But what if,
and what if the fairly gap was here? And this is just an example and there was an inverse
for the gap, right?
The apologies.
So, what would happen?
My take profit level would be here.
So, I would increase my stop like that until I get 1 to 1 risk total watt, right?
So, now we do not have a stop above here, but somewhere around here, because we need to get at least 1 to 1.
Otherwise, your risk reward and your total, I would say profit factor would be very low, okay?
Okay, so make sure you're getting at least one to one and then you can hold the trades if you want to till then like the
Significant target level is hit
This is very simple and this is why I call it the juggernaut because it is very quick and it is very powerful
It has over 70% win rate and notice
Wash the video again because
Make sure first off that there is only one fairly app, right?
and wait for a formation of IFPG or in virtual gap and free on the close or on the retest and target this level
Now here's another way to look at it. So
You would get like a
Market structure shift so now once you get a market structure shift right this leg right here
Right you have to look for a single fair value gap inside this leg because now we had swept this low
And we can also consider this as a market structure shift.
So previously, if I go here, we had a break of structure, right?
And we looked for a fairly gap in the this leg that broke the structure.
But if we remove this and now we look at the.
At this, right? We had a market structure shift.
Now inside this leg that did the marker structure shift or swept the liquidity right you have to look for a
Singular freer value gap and the singular freer value gap. Let's assume it's right here
All right, you keep going higher you keep going to a high time frame until you see
You know a single fairway, but you can stay on one minute
And if you see like a single freer value gap from this range high to this range low
Then you should be good now
All you're looking for is price to close above this level once the price closes this old
Fair value gap becomes inverse fair value gap and from there almost you're looking to take you and to you on the retest
And you're targeting the most recent high or most recent or more the closest the closest
Liquidy level and that is gonna be this high over here
So your end to it be here. You stop with go. Let's go. Let's suppose you go
long here. If I so move your take profit level and we decrease the stop to till this level
and we get 1.33 and we can then hold if you want to take some price as I said before.
Now let me give you guys some examples and then everything is going to be clear.